a new morning consult poll commissioned
by politico a left-wing outlet has
terrible news for democrats
republicans are trouncing them on almost
all of the important issues heading into
the midterms
on handling inflation voters favor
republicans over democrats 46 to 32
percent
on the economy at large voters trust
republicans 47 to 36 percent national
security republicans win 48 to 35
percent
immigration republicans win 45 to 38
on guns republicans take it by the same
margin
and on energy the parties are evenly
split but even those numbers don't tell
the whole story according to msnbc not
exactly a conservative outlet democrats
are in quote shellacking territory on
all three aspects of their midterm meter
presidential approval rating down at 40
percent
belief that the country is on the wrong
track that's all the way it's 71 percent
and the generic ballot which has
republicans up two percent doesn't sound
like a lot but it's actually pretty
significant when you look at all the
races even that
doesn't tell the whole story because
when you substitute in actual republican
candidates for the issues questions and
the generic republicans in these polls
the numbers look even better for
republicans a new poll of the florida
gubernatorial race has republican
governor ron desantis up
16 points on his nearest challenger that
would be the former republican current
democrat charlie crist desantis is up 19
points on his next nearest challenger
democrat annette tadeo and he's up a
whopping 24 points on the democrats
former favorite challenger nicki freed
if nothing substantially changes between
now and november the elections are
slated to be an electoral bloodbath for
democrats
republicans should run away with them by
every meaningful
metric if
the elections are fair and square
it's a big if
why aren't democrats changing strategy
on energy national security immigration
the economy everything else they're
doubling down on all the same policies
that are killing them in the polls
which can mean only one of three things
one
they don't want to win seems unlikely
two
they don't believe the polls i guess
that's possible or three most
disconcerting of all
they think they can win without the
votes
i'm glad you like that clip now you
gotta subscribe ring the bell get all
the notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]